[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHISHIR AGRAWAL: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for
joining this session
on GCP Network Performance
Monitoring and Diagnostics
Customer Panel.
My name is Shishir Agrawal.
I'm a product manager in
the Cloud Networking Team,
and I lead Google's efforts
around network performance
monitoring and diagnostics.
So I'm sure all of you are
having a great Next so far,
and you have probably attended
sessions where you learned more
about Google's cloud
networking solutions,
whether it's high performance
network, global VPCs, load
balancers, and other
capabilities we have.
While that's great
and that enables
you to migrate your
workloads to Google Cloud,
but on a day-to-day basis,
when you are managing
your network as network
admins and operators,
you want to make
sure that you can
do that very, very efficiently.
And one of the big charters
that we have within Google Cloud
Networking is to make that
day-to-day operations much,
much easier and seamless.
And I lead the
charter to provide
a set of tools and
capabilities for our customers
to make that easier, to allow
you to better monitor, manage,
diagnose your network.
As part of that, we
have been talking
to a lot of customers
over the past few months,
working closely with
our user research team,
and we have talked them
over 20-plus customers.
So the goal of this
session is really
to talk to you about
some of those learnings
that we had from
those user interviews.
I have with me two of our
customers from Global Payment
and Cardinal Health along
with a partner, Kentik,
and Gargi from our
Engineering Leadership Team.
This is definitely a big
area of focus for us,
and we would love to hear from
more of you around your pain
points around--
in this space and
partner with you.
So again, this is
the panel, and we'll
introduce the panel shortly.
Again, I want to thank
all my panelists today
here for joining with
me in this session
just as a reminder hopefully
you probably saw this
in other sessions as
well, we are actually
going to use Dory Q&A as
well, along with if any of you
have questions, please
line up along the mic.
But you can also
go to the Next app,
click the Dory Q&A link
there, and actually post
questions on Dory.
And towards the
end of the session,
I'll be looking at Dory and
answering those questions.
But what it also allows us is to
actually answer those questions
even after the session.
So feel free to post questions
during the session or even
after the session,
and we will definitely
make sure to respond
to those questions.
So quick agenda for today.
We'll do-- again, I'll
spend quite a bit of time
on panel discussion,
learning from our customers.
I'll also talk about
some of the solutions
we have today for monitoring
and diagnostics within GCP.
And then Kentik, who
is one of our partners,
will talk about how they
leverage some of the GCP
products to provide
visibility to our customers
and show a quick demo.
And then obviously I will
you leave enough time
for audience Q&A.
So with that in mind,
let's jump on to the panel
portion of the session.
And I'll start with having
each of the panelists
quickly introduce themselves.
So Ed, would you like
to introduce yourself?
ED HAMMOND: Ed Hammond,
Senior Enterprise Architect
for Cardinal Health.
We're a large, Fortune
500 kind of company,
based in Dublin, Ohio.
KELLY WANG: Kelly Wang,
Senior Solution Architect
from Global Payments.
We are a global payment
provider world-wide.
JUSTIN RYBURN: Thank you.
Justin Ryburn,
director of solutions
engineering at Kentik, and we'll
talk a little later about who
Kentik is and what we do.
But as Shishir mentioned, we're
a partner of Google's and happy
to be here.
GARGI ADHAV: Thank you.
I'm Gargi Adhav.
Also I am partner in
crime with Shishir
on the Network
Performance Diagnostics
initiative within Google.
And I manage on the config
distribution pipeline
that you don't see, that
is hidden behind everything
that you configure, and
external facing cloud routing,
cloud router VPC peering.
So we see a lot of problems,
I hear a lot from customers,
in terms of when they
do configurations,
what are their pain points?
So I'll be here to
hear from our panelists
on some of their pain points
and hear from you as well.
And we'll talk about what
we can do to address it.
SHISHIR AGRAWAL:
Thank you, everyone.
Let's jump right in.
So I'll start with just asking,
like what are one or two
key pain points that you have
around network performance
monitoring and diagnostics,
especially when you
look at your infrastructure or
applications running in cloud?
And maybe if you can give some
examples of some issues that
have happened or some outages
that might have happened.
And Ed, maybe I'll
start with you here?
ED HAMMOND: Sure, I've got
the mic, so I'll start.
Well, one of the problems
is we have a large staff
and things are moving
very, very quickly.
Things are changing
all the time.
I'll give you a case in point.
Recently, a very
skilled network engineer
was trying to work on
a particular problem
between shared VPCs
and that kind of thing.
And he had totally forgotten
that we had multiple other VPCs
in a post static route
in one of the VPCs
which propagated to on prem
routers and took out routes.
And that wasn't very nice.
That was one that was--
if he had just stepped
back and actually looked
at the configuration
a little bit better,
he would've found it.
He knew it was there but
had forgotten about it.
It didn't scream at him before
he put in that configuration.
There was another
one that we had
where we had a database
release, application
release that we were
moving into the cloud.
And they put the
database in one VPC
and they put the
application in another VPC.
That's not very good
for performance.
So we were exiting Iowa
and going up to Chicago
and back to Iowa for every
single database call.
That added significant latency.
So again, in that case,
it was on the console,
and everybody looked
at it, including me.
And we didn't see it.
It wasn't intuitively
obvious to us.
So if we had a clear methodology
there, that would help us.
SHISHIR AGRAWAL:
That's a great example.
Thank you.
KELLY WANG: Thank you.
So the challenge we're
facing is that we
have a different workload.
We have different
requirements which
requires some of
the workload we're
putting in the shared VPC.
Some, they are in their own VPC.
So the challenge
we're facing is we
want to know at any single
point how many VPCs we own.
Within a particular VPCs, how
many projects are associate,
how many public IPs we own.
And within each this, if
we change firewall rules,
how many VMs will get impact.
So currently the
challenges we're facing
is that there are missing
a single pane of view
from a network
monitoring perspective.
And those are one of the
challenge we're facing.
The other things
we're facing is if we
want to do some
connectivity diagnosis,
we want to know point
to point what are the--
is there a connectivity
between them,
and what's the-- if
there are, what what's
the latencies between them?
If there is no connectivity,
what might be the issue?
So those are the challenges
we're facing today.
SHISHIR AGRAWAL:
Thank you, Kelly.
For Justin, I mean we
heard from our customers,
but as a partner, I'm sure you
talk to a lot of customers.
So you can you share
your views on what do you
hear from customers?
JUSTIN RYBURN: Yeah, absolutely.
I think when we
talk to customers
about the performance monitoring
diagnostics challenges
that they have in their network
and in their infrastructure
in Google Cloud, it
usually comes down
a lot of call three buckets.
And I think Ed and Kelly
hit on a number of those--
it's cost.
So using as example of
traffic exiting one VPC
and coming back into
another, performance
is one aspect of that.
But there's a cost
to that as well.
So if you optimize
your applications
and you have the
applications database running
in the same VPC, you avoid cost
of that traffic hair-pinning,
if you want to
phrase it that way.
The second one is
performance, as Ed mentioned,
and in the third bucket that
we hear a lot from customers,
is security.
How do I know that the policies
and the security posture that I
think I have both in
my physical data center
as well as in my Cloud are
actually being enforced?
Is traffic getting
through that shouldn't be?
And am I unintentionally
blocking traffic
that I otherwise
need to allow through
as part of my as part of
my security infrastructure?
Because configuring
ACLs in the VPCs
can be fairly complex as
your environment scales out.
So those are kind
of the three buckets
of challenges that we hear from
customers when we talk to them.
SHISHIR AGRAWAL: Thanks Justin.
So Gargi, I mean, as I
mentioned at the beginning,
we have actually talked
a lot of customers.
And a lot of these
themes we have heard--
would you like to elaborate
a bit on maybe something else
that we have heard
from customers?
GARGI ADHAV: Yeah, sure.
So when Ed was
talking and Justin
as well about the
performance thing, that
is like a resounding thing that
we've heard from customers,
especially when their
performance deteriorates
that they would--
they today have
no way of knowing why
is that deteriorating,
where is the
bottleneck, and so on.
So there has been
a resounding thing.
The other part of it is
the configuration changes.
And sometimes if it
is a syntax error,
then yes obviously GCP
will throw an error
and you will find
out immediately.
But syntactically, your
configuration could be correct.
It could be accepted by the
VMs and everything as fine,
but then suddenly there will
be some impact on your traffic
a few minutes later.
And sometimes they don't
even have visibility
because they do have multiple
network admins and security
admins who are both
changing things.
So maybe nothing changed in
the networking conflicts.
But the security admin came
and added an extra firewall
rule or something.
And then it goes all the
way up to troubleshooting
your network, and then the
app admins come and say, hey,
my service is not available
to this XYZ customer.
And go and see it's
a network problem.
So figuring out what the root
cause and the pain point is
and where exactly
something went wrong
is a sounding thing we've
heard from many of you.
SHISHIR AGRAWAL: Thanks, Gargi.
So I guess, I mean, if I
were to just summarize this,
I think we heard a
bit about security's
obviously top of mind.
How do you make sure you
have the right security
posture and firewall rules?
Kelly talked about
configuration changes
and how do you make sure any
kind of connectivity issues,
especially in that
hybrid environment,
you can actually make sure
that any of the configuration
changes would not cause
that connectivity issue.
And I'd actually had
a very good example
of somebody cleaning
their static routes
and causing connectivity
to be broken.
So just by show of
hand, I mean what
percentage of network outages
and performance issues
happened because of
configuration changes?
Anybody want to take a guess
at the percentage here?
AUDIENCE: 80%.
SHISHIR AGRAWAL: 80%.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: 60%.
SHISHIR AGRAWAL: 60%.
Actually that's very close.
I mean the data is--
the data shows that about
75% of network outages
and configuration happen
because of configuration related
changes--
AUDIENCE: You could
say I was closer.
SHISHIR AGRAWAL: Yeah.
One of you are closer.
So again, I think
the point being
that hopefully most
of you in the room
are related to the
network team and you
can realize that configuration
does cost a lot of outages.
So moving on to the next
part, maybe the next question
I would like to ask the
panelists is about some
of the tools and
solutions they are
using to address
these challenges
and do monitoring and
diagnostics-- whether it's
homegrown, whether it's
Google-provided solutions,
or whether it's a third party.
So maybe, Kelly, I would
like to start with you here
and if you want to talk
about some solutions you use?
KELLY WANG: All right.
So today we are--
have stacks of some
solutions and tools
together to help us with
monitoring and diagnosis.
From the platform
perspective, we
are-- turn on all
the VPC Flow Logs,
which give us the network
performance information.
They also provide
security posture for us.
So we know from a particular IP
what's a resource he's touching
and at what time.
So and those are at
the VPC Flow Log level.
We also turn on the
firewall rule logs as well.
So those give us the firewall
rules changing information,
and what are the allowed--
what are the denied
firewall rules?
Other than the
platform-provided capabilities,
we also rely on the traditional
layer 2, layer 3 tools
as well like Trace Route.
And also on top of
that, we also want
to get like network
topology information.
And those are we are currently
introduce a third party too.
ED HAMMOND: We too use
firewall logs very heavily.
I'll give you an example.
We have instances that
are running on premise
and we bring them
into the cloud.
As we bring them
into the cloud, we're
trying to do micro segmentation.
So we're using a
particular firewall rule
that we apply to
all these instances.
And then we look at the
log traffic of that,
and then we can lock
down the instances
with the specific
firewall rule logs.
That turned out to be a
significant amount of effort
that we had to develop
these tools about,
so having intelligent
firewall log
management would
be very helpful,
as well as explaining that
to application developers who
don't necessarily understand
how all their applications work.
I'm sure our developers
are unique in that regard.
As well as the performance--
Kelly mentioned the performance.
So we've actually installed
third party tools,
where at different
points in our network
we have instrumentation points.
And so we can tell
response times
between different segments.
And that turns out to be really
sensitive to our applications--
2 or 3 milliseconds seems to
be very sensitive at times.
SHISHIR AGRAWAL: OK.
Thank you.
So apparently, I
mean you are-- both
of you are using VPC firewall
logs and VPC Flow Logs.
And again, just quick poll among
the audience-- how many of you
are using the VPC Flow
Logs and Firewall Logs
for monitoring or diagnostics?
So not a whole lot.
So again, in the later
part of the presentation,
I'll actually talk a bit
more about VPC Flow Logs
and firewall logs.
But that is actually--
we see that a lot
among our customers using VPC
Flow Logs and firewall logs.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ED HAMMOND: Why not
contact me afterwards?
KELLY WANG: Yeah,
that's my answer too.
SHISHIR AGRAWAL: Yeah, and
I'll actually talk about some
of the partner ecosystem we
have in a subsequent slide.
But definitely we are--
again with Google
we are obviously
providing you code capabilities
as part of the platform.
But we have an open
ecosystem where
we have a lot of partners
that integrate with us
via the logs or the APIs.
So a lot of customers do that.
OK, so the next question
I would like to ask
is, if you had a
magic wand and if you
were to wish, I would say,
one or two key capabilities
that GCP would provide you
that would make the life of you
as a network admin operator
enterprise architect easier,
what would those one
or two things would be?
And Kelly, maybe I would--
KELLY WANG: I'll start.
So I want to have a
platform provide me
a view which this will--
even the operator, the operation
team, they don't have--
they're not be a very
skilled network engineer.
They can come into
this tool and the
are from this
platform-provided view there,
they can find the
topology information.
So they can see, what
are the VPCs we own.
Within each VPC, what's
my topology views?
And inside this VPC,
per subnet, how many
VMs are associated with?
How many public IPs are
associated with a VPC?
associated under our account.
And also I wish we have
this view capabilities.
We can monitoring the network
performance inside of--
I go into the VPC Flow Logs.
We have that information
in the flow log,
but it is very time consuming
to get that information today.
So if we have this
view, that would
be ideal for operation team
in case there's incidents
happening, they can
do the first phase
triad without involving
a whole bigger team.
And also if this tool provided
diagnostic capability,
so they can provide
point-to-point connectivity
information and tell
what the latencies are,
and those will be the things
I think of my top wish list.
SHISHIR AGRAWAL:
OK, thanks Kelly.
Ed?
ED HAMMOND: I have to echo
a lot what Kelly said.
One of the other things
about performance
is that you can
use it as a canary
as to whether
something's going wrong.
For example, if I
know that I normally
have traffic going from US
central to, I don't know,
Europe or whatever, and it's
supposed to take so much time,
and then all of a sudden
it starts inching up,
I know that I'm doing
something somewhere that
could indicate a failure.
Now, we always want the
network to be highly resilient.
But I want to be able to
detect that and alarm--
not necessarily alarm
but give trend analysis,
so that I can understand when
something has gone wrong.
So sometimes those are
very, very subtle signals.
And if you don't look
at it all the time--
I don't about you, but I don't
look at all these reports
all the time--
if you don't look
at it all the time,
you could miss these things.
Was it 1.2 seconds or
was it 1.7 seconds?
I don't remember.
And so having a
tool that would be
very sensitive in that regard.
The other one is in
that firewall rules--
when somebody's going
to put something
in knowing what the effect
is before it happens
would be a really
good thing to have
before I go change a
static route, knowing
before it happens that I'm
going to have a BGP propagation
problem.
That would be really,
really nice to know.
So I think with a
lot of capabilities
that Google can do,
they're in a great position
to help us with that.
SHISHIR AGRAWAL: Great, great.
Thank you.
So I think what I heard
about just to summarize some
of the things, I
think Kelly mentioned
about getting a
topology view, maybe
getting better
performance metrics right
out the out of the box as
opposed to mining a lot of data
and mining a lot of information.
And I think Ed's
wish is how they
can manage configuration
changes, which
is even before things happen.
So and I know Gargi here
has the magic wand, I think.
So Gargi, do you want to
address some of what we
have heard from the customers?
And maybe talk a
bit about at least
how Google is
looking at addressing
some of these problems?
GARGI ADHAV: Sure, sure.
So obviously, like
Shishir mentioned,
we have VPC logs
and VPC Flow Logs,
Firewall Logs that help you
troubleshoot your problems
and help us troubleshoot
if those logs are enabled.
But it looks like not many of
you have been using it so far.
But some of our partners,
including some here,
they also shared that they
use-- have those logs,
and then they write scripts
on top of those logs to find--
do fine-tune and identify where
is the needle in the haystack.
But one of the things
that we've been hearing
is, like finding the
needle in the haystack,
whether Google can
help you with that.
And that's exactly
what we're going to do.
Because there is a lot of
information, like Kelly said.
It's hidden and it's
hard to go and navigate
because you don't even
anticipate that, oh,
this thing under this tree would
have some information in there.
So that is definitely
something that can helps it.
But one thing I'd like
to ask all of you,
because we've heard so much
about configuration problems
from all our customers
and Justin here as well,
how many of you are afraid
to make configuration changes
or have config change
as a pain point?
Like if we can have
a show of hands,
is that one of your
biggest pain points?
How many of you here have that?
That you'd like to have more--
OK, slowly raising the hands.
ED HAMMOND: You must not
make any changes, obviously.
GARGI ADHAV: Yeah, yeah, cool.
So that is an area definitely
that we are looking into.
And if you are interested
in solving that pain point,
do connect with us offline.
Shishir is definitely
driving this flowed
from the product side.
We also have a UX
Reserach lead back there
who's engaging with
a lot of customers
and finding out
their pin points so
that we can feed it into the
products that we are building.
That is definitely an
area, a magic wand--
SHISHIR AGRAWAL: Thanks Gargi.
And again, I think as Gargi
said, and some of the pain
points that you heard about--
whether it's topology,
providing better
performance information,
or allowing your
customers to diagnose
connectivity issues
due to configuration
or enabling them to make
configuration changes more
confidently-- so we understand
all of those pain points.
We would like to actually
hear more from any of you
who has insights
into those use cases.
But again, watch out.
And we are looking
at these problems
and how we can solve
these problems.
GARGI ADHAV: One of
the things is also,
customers ask us, whenever
there is a problem,
there is an app admin who's
separate from the network
admin.
So they say, just tell me
whether it's an application
problem or it's a network
problem, networking problem.
So even getting to that
point it takes them time
before they figure that out
and obviously or person hours.
So that is another area
that we can help you with.
So do connect with
us offline if these
are some of your pain points.
SHISHIR AGRAWAL: So
thank you, everyone.
I think that was great
insights and great feedback,
and I hope all of you
attending could hopefully
relate to some of
these pain points
and could see how Google
is looking to address this.
So I want to actually
kind of change gears
a little bit and talk about what
are the existing solutions that
are available today that
a lot of our customers
use, and actually you can
go back and use as well.
So one of the key capabilities
that we have is VPC Flow Logs.
And again, the idea
here is that we
record a sample of
the network flows
that are sent or received
by the VM instances.
Those flows are aggregated
every 5 seconds.
And actually with
the new capability
that's currently in
beta, you can actually
configure that integral.
A lot of our customers
use VPC Flow Logs
for a variety of use cases.
The first one is obviously
in network monitoring,
where they can look
at the flow data,
look at kind of who are
the top talkers, where
is the traffic coming from, even
use that data for optimizing
their expenses or network.
Security again, a
lot of customers pipe
VPC Flow Logs to
maybe a sim solution
and look at whether the
connections are happening
from legit IP addresses or not.
So then they can apply the
right kind of policies.
You can view these VPC flow
logs in the stack driver,
and then also you can export
it to Cloud Pub/Sub or BigQuery
or a third party
solution like Sims.
And one of the key capabilities
that actually a lot of you who
might have used VPC
Flow Logs have asked us
around how can you reduce
the volume of VPC Flow Logs--
so again we have some new
controls available now, which
is in beta, to actually allow
you to reduce the VPC Flow Logs
volume.
So you can control the
time interval in which
the aggregation happens.
So by default, it happens
every five seconds,
but now you can set it to 30
seconds, a minute, 10 minutes,
or 15 minutes.
Similarly for log entry
sampling, so we sample--
so when we write the
logs to the database,
there is a sampling
that happens.
And by default, the sampling
ratio is 0.5 or 50%,
but now actually can control
it you can set it to 100%
or on the extreme and
you can set it to 0%.
So that's another
control let's have
a label along with
metadata annotations
where the notion is that
when we write VPC Flow Logs,
we actually write the source and
destination VM instance names.
We write the
geographical information
in terms of regions.
So all of that you can actually
choose to not annotate your VPC
Flow Logs, because your use case
might be simply to know the IP
addresses.
So those are the controls
that are available to you.
And the other key
capabilities is Firewall Logs.
So this allows you to actually
audit, verify, and analyze
the effects of your
firewall rules.
So you can actually
understand if a firewall rule
that you have, it is doing
what is intended to do.
So for example, if it's
blocking the traffic
that you want it to block.
So you enable these
firewall rules,
logging on a per rule basis.
And unlike VPC Flow Logs,
these are not samples.
So these are available
for every connection.
And you can see them in
a Stackdriver logging
or exported to a pub
server or BigQuery.
In addition to logging
within the Cloud console,
we also have very, very rich
monitoring capabilities.
So on the service pages, and
I am taking an example of VPN
here.
If you go to the VPN
page, you can actually
see some key information for
monitoring out of the box.
You can see what is
the VPN general status.
If it's green, as in
if it's established,
or it might be red,
which means that it's not
seeing any incoming packets.
This is some basic level
of monitoring that you
see on the service pages.
And similarly you will
see for interconnect.
But then we publish
a lot of metrics
that you can see
in the Stackdriver.
So Stackdriver has out
of the box dashboards.
For example, if you go to
resources under Stackdriver,
under Services VPN,
we actually are now
publishing metrics such
as terminal status,
received bytes, packet loss--
which is dropped packets,
which is one of the key metrics
that customers want to look at.
And then you can set
alerts on these metrics.
And depending on the
thresholds you want.
So you can say, if my
packet drop is less than--
or is more than whatever point,
0.1%, I want to get an alert.
But these dashboards are
available out of the box.
And last, but again
very important,
we have a rich
partner ecosystem.
So to some of the question that
somebody was asking earlier,
we have integrations with Sim
partners for VPC Flow Logs
and Firewall Logs.
So you can send data to similar
Sumo Logic or Splunk solutions.
A lot of customers use
next generation firewall,
such as Palo Alto
or Fortinet or Check
Point where, again,
they're sitting in line
and it has full visibility
of the traffic that's
flowing through your network.
And for compliance
reasons, we have, again,
a lot of vendors or partners who
integrate with VPC Flow Logs.
And again, you'll hear from
one of the partners, Kentik,
in a minute.
But that's another
integration that's available.
So with that, I think
it's a good segue
into the last
section here, where
I would invite Justin
to talk about Kentik
and show us a quick demo.
JUSTIN RYBURN: All
right, thank you Shishir.
So for those who aren't
familiar with Kentik,
I'll be brief on this, but
just kind of a quick overview
about who Kentik is.
We're about a five-year-old
startup that's
based here in San Francisco.
We've seen good success
over the last five years
across what we call digital
enterprise as well as
the service provider community.
This is how our
platform is built.
So as Shishir mentioned,
that the Google VPC Flow
Logs can be exported
to a Pub/Sub bus
and then basically you can
figure your VPCs to send
those logs to that bus and
then you configure our system
to listen, to subscribe
to that conversation,
pull those flow logs
back into our system.
And then we enrich
that with a lot
of different pieces of context.
So Flow Logs out of
the box from Google
give you a lot of
good information,
as Shishir mentioned,
around what's the VM source?
What's the zone source
What's the project source?
There's a lot of good, rich
information that's in there.
But we also have some additional
metadata that will enrich with
as well things from
Kubernetes or Istio
if you're running those
type of service mesh setups.
We can find out a little bit
more information about pods
and nodes and so forth.
And then once we have
those logs into our system,
I'll give you some examples of
what some of the UI screenshots
would look like.
We give you all
kinds of insights
about what your traffic
looks like in both our UI
is as well as give
you an API that's
available to pull that data
out if you want to integrate it
with another system.
And then all kinds of proactive
notifications and alerts
that you can use to
find out proactively
about changes in your network
environment, in your VPCs.
So what are some
of the use cases
and why would people use Kentik?
And a lot of it comes down
to the persona of the user.
So for our network operations
and our network engineering
teams, kind of to the point
that Gargi made earlier,
the age old question--
is it the application
or is it the network?
And so using Kentik and
looking at the flow logs
and finding out, am I seeing
an increase in latency
for just a single application,
all the applications
in a single VPC, can give me
some clues and some indicators
into, is my network
performance-- is it
a network performance issue
or is it an application
performance issue?
Which is really powerful to our
network operations, our network
engineering users.
On the sec ops
side, it comes back
to I think what I was mentioning
earlier about security.
Is the security
posture that I believe
I have enforced
actually working the way
that I believe it is once my
configuration gets applied?
And I allowing things
through that shouldn't be?
Am I blocking things that
I mean to allow through?
On the SRE and dev
ops side, there's
a lot of trying to figure out
what applications are talking
to what other applications.
And I mentioned, we
have a rich API that
allows you to pull some of
this data out, which allows you
to automate a lot
of your systems
to do some automation
built on top of changes
to network traffic patterns
or certain traffic patterns
that you see in
your environment.
And then for the
executives, we have
sort of a higher level dashboard
so they can get a view of,
how many VPC do I have?
How much traffic is
coming in and out of them?
How is my cloud
network performing?
Just some screenshots
as examples
that might be interesting to
network engineering and network
operations.
This is what we call
a Sankey diagram,
and this shows coming out
of one particular project,
it's spread across US--
well, US East and US West.
What are the destination IP
addresses that that traffic is
flowing to?
And what is the application
this particular case?
Of course, it's a
secure web application.
So as a network engineering
or network operations user,
I can quickly see how my how
my network is performing.
For security operations,
again, like I said,
it's really about what--
are their data exfiltration
events going on?
Is my security policy
being applied the way
that I think it's being applied?
This is where the
proactive notifications
come in really useful, is I can
get notifications when there's
a new event that takes
place in the network,
and then drill down and get
a lot more detail about what
that network event is.
Latency-- so this
is something that
is a really powerful
feature that Google enables
by putting latency information
in each one of the flow
logs that they export.
Now I can look at,
on a per application
basis, what is my latency?
And am I seeing an increase in
the latency of my application.
So in this particular
example here on the slide,
you see just one
application out of many
has a huge spike in its latency.
So that gives me an
indicator that likely this
is a network-- or an application
latency issue and not a network
issue.
And so I can try and defend
myself as a networking guy
and say no, it's
not the VPC network,
it's something to do
with your application.
And then like I said, for the
executives, a dashboard that
shows a lot of
different views of,
how is the network
performing at a high level?
How much traffic do I have?
Where is it coming from?
Where is it going to?
And how much is it costing me?
So as an example, more
concrete, we here at Kentik
have an application
we call the Sock
Shop that's running on GCPs.
So this is an example workload.
It's a microservices
containerized application
that has various pieces to it.
It has a card, it has a catalog.
And so as a user that runs
this e-commerce website,
there are a couple of
things that I can look at.
So the first thing
that I look at
is a dashboard that
shows me all of my VPC
traffic for this application.
It shows me my traffic zone
to zone, region to region,
project to project.
So I can kind of see how
are the various pieces
of my application running.
And to Ed's point earlier,
I can try and look forward,
do I have
inefficiencies in where
my workloads have been placed?
Do I have the cart
or the catalog
running in a different
VPC than what
I have my database running in?
And is that something that
I could better optimize?
And then this is
another view that
gives us some information about
this microservices application
that's running.
It's showing me the various
pieces of the application
and what's talking to what.
So my front end
website, for example,
talking back to the
Sock Shop, the catalog
talking to the cart.
There's a lot of
different interactions
that are happening
in that application.
And I can see how each one
of those maps to each other,
whether that be bits per
second, whether that be
packets per second, or
even latency information.
I can drill down and get
a lot more information
about how the
application is performing
and look for
inefficiencies in how
that application is performing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]